[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
yeah let us know how it goes we're
talking about suspect shoes
off here we're talking about suspects
watches suspect
all suspect everything sucks back on
yeah sometimes it's tough
but also i know it was real y'all went
to the gym yesterday
oh did whatever what's called zoo zoo
culture
zoo culture wait can we help them you
for sure oh yeah they
are very vocal okay like they don't have
instagram
like you're part of some secret society
yeah should we talk about that
so funny i pulled up i was like i got no
mask i said you don't need no [ __ ]
mask in here
i was like for real and then obviously
where he was standing he was standing
inside the gym he's like
so chappelle's done his thing he's like
yo dog check out this gym people tell us
to go up there
and it says woodland hills on i'm like
damn that has to be close to me i map
quest
it's super close i never knew about it
you never knew about it
never even heard of it never oh then we
roll up there and that place was
lit lit nowhere to park yeah yeah
we were we were by far this not only
probably the fattest dudes in there
also the ugliest oh bro well a lot of we
didn't we didn't
not belong in there a lot of influence
we were walking around we had hoodies on
and [ __ ]
everybody shredded it everyone straight
had their shirts dude there's
i mean it's it's like vintage gold's gym
venice 90s like
yeah dudes helping each other out
yeah very homoerotic yes you gotta
lift his buddy on his shoulder but it
wasn't gay it was they were [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you try to you saw all the you saw your
competition oh
i haven't been in like a real gym like
that in a hot second we put five plates
on each side
you know why because last episode bryan
said you could deadlift like five places
and all that and wait a minute
something do something to do something
you got it yeah i'm still strong
but i just haven't done anything i was
so embarrassed it was like that
that that didn't scrape the way don't
take the weight the ig influencer girl
was watching me i was like
oh then we were trying to adjust the
incline bit stop it
it was too low so i go hey you got to
raise this up
oh man it was so bad he was just shaking
why did you just he take the weight off
bro why are you thinking
because i was trying to adjust the
racket yeah he had no racket so he just
had to hold it
that gym was dope though this is this is
post rib uh
how many people were in the gym when
they saw this tragedy
yeah to the window to the wall it was
pretty packed they were like
filming something they were all the
influencers go there to film their best
workouts
yeah yeah because yeah when i rolled up
there's some dude was like
now bring them up their social media
culture
culture because where's that yeah
because bradley
bradley the owner nice guy yeah
yeah nice really nice guy what check it
out you were a nice guy really i talked
to him for probably an hour before you
got it yeah
cool hustler cool dude cut from the same
cloth really good dude
okay he's in a uh theo pushing that
culture
he uh is it spelled a certain way
uh okay that's it probably zoo with two
o's
zoe culture look at this yeah we saw
that dirt bike she sent this down
so that's it that's the gym dog yeah
that's it
damn yep i mean he's even fit
oh he's shredded that's him dude i
look crazy i look like [ __ ] next to him
bro
i'm talking all these girls growing past
like
he's like yeah man you come in here
anytime you want like yelping
everyone looks like this all the time is
oh he's just saying [ __ ] man usually i
was like yeah no no
i've never been in a gym where everyone
yeah i everywhere i've never been in the
gym when i was the most out of shape guy
yeah are you serious i mean for sure
why would you send him that gym if you
knew no it was lit
it was good we had a blast yeah we had a
bunch because bradley
uh who came in there yeah he's dope and
then
go back to him because he's in court
today because his gym stays open like
the city has uh
of la has 15 criminal uh misdemeanor
charges against me and continuing her
ask me to close down my gym without any
proof that my gym being open
has caused any coverage spread no cases
someone help this makes sense
yeah damn ain't he a real g too i like
that
he's a real one he's entrepreneur has
his own merch crushes with merch
shout out to raw gear everyone is dude
everyone
hey everybody juicy everybody
me and brenda kept the hoodies
i don't know if you can on you're too
skinny what do you mean yeah
you'll be too soft to do something they
don't have weights for your size
everything started at hundo that's small
i like how justin was like hey let me
come with y'all
i'll meet you i've done it
like if we're on a roster if it's a
53-man roster
yeah i'm 52 you're 53. oh 100 we're not
playing in the game
we're not playing in the game at all so
you have to be honest now
to be fair though we're on different
supplements than them
what you mean we are oh they are
everybody juicy
oh okay look at that i'm all here for it
your boy should all do some [ __ ] man
that's what it takes to be part of the
zoo culture yeah jessica could get
probably get like that dude
no no no no no no shredded asian
you know hard as he gets shredded well
he looks short though short
look at his [ __ ] legs they look like
a leaf oh [ __ ] never mind
they look like a [ __ ] maple leaf held
up to the light just they are
just a super he's too skinny you're
right they don't have weights for you
guys
i hate these [ __ ] well i'm looking
listen i'll i'll talk to my boy i'll
talk to my boy and see if we can get in
yeah i'll talk to bradley i doubt
otherwise also hey bradley am i at
hooters
wait bradley am i am am i at twin peaks
because if i
am get me a [ __ ] beer bro who do you
mean
we kept going i'm just trying to work
out and then and then i get to work out
jump off and go women
the most gorgeous women in the world
work out there well you know all these
uh
these ig models they go there to post
their videos
tick-tock that's where summer rae works
out sometimes
and this girl is that her is that her
man i think your boy brian ortega
actually did a meet and greet with her
at that gym
oh that guy's skinny i could keep my
hair yeah
dude he's holding the camera oh he's
filming addison ray do her [ __ ]
okay gotcha that's the reason i like
that you know addison ray
how do you know she's also a youtuber
right
she's on he does music yeah all uh no
not music but
uh all tick talkers are kind of like
youtubers
yeah yeah a lot of body rolls yeah a lot
of like but uh
i've been every gym in the world i've
been so many gyms yeah this gym is
[ __ ] dope man
it was dope it was the first time i felt
normal in la in a year
oh being in that gym any machines like
so many machines
yeah they they got everything yeah and
they're moving a new spot yeah now
parking's gonna be a little tough
parking was because the landlord is a
[ __ ] hater he makes it real difficult
he ropes off the
parking lot because he doesn't want
people coming in there oh
they trying to stop him yeah but this
dude says [ __ ] that noise and gets it
done
so we are parked at the party like
and it was worth it yeah yeah i'll go
back for sure yeah we'll go yeah we're
members now we're members
oh [ __ ] wait hold on hold on how did the
two eyes
but it is weird to shut down a gym
because we know people that are in shape
they get covered it you know if you're
promoting health
it was a good way to combat covet
where's ryan garcia
yeah ain't no man i could come in there
he did he's way too but
also get a smaller shirt ryan
hey ryan big fan here a big small shirt
a huge man
i think they posted on their instagram
story yesterday that chuck liddell was
there yesterday too
y'all saw chuck no we did not oh yeah
chocolate
we were trying we were trying i think
everybody in like the calabasas area
would go to that gym if you're looking
for like a gym like a straight up raw
dog
pumping iron gym this is it oh yeah it
is i'm trying to get spray tan i'm
trying to get on that
juice do you want to let my legs hang
out gta
yeah our goal yep go ahead good good
our goal is to be able to take our
shirts off too
one black guy looked like chuck congo
was doing those biceps i was like god
dude
oh shoot who's that hey man i don't know
but
which one that's summer rae about this
oh there's that's about that ashlane
no sarah but this is 2019 dude
oh wow that's old yeah this this uh just
got three people
to get your money so crazy i've never
heard of this person in my life they got
3.5 million
that's how it is like everything these
days are like niche markets like
everyone has their own
following yeah and then i'm sure she has
merch and she's selling skinny tea
yeah she's selling she plays football
stop it she ain't nfl street
stop it she catching football so
hold on hold on i'm about to follow her
she just gained the follower
oh oh no that's fake that's no that's
right
she caught it yeah she's got herself
damn she's kind of badass
bro damn hold on
on the ball stop it that's [ __ ]
impressive yeah that's great
how about the spiderman oh yeah go ahead
how about the culture appropriation with
the braids
black history month right all right girl
get a little too comfortable yeah i like
that shout out to her and she let go
that woman was she living away with the
iron the bar i want to see that the what
the one arm snatch let me see
oh she's doing it pushing one guy she's
a beast oh she's lifting wait stop it
what is she singing let's see let's take
a little break here because listen man
i'm here to talk about insurance
sounds boring but it's super important
insurance can be complicated can be
super super intimidating so thank god
for the zebra
the zebra was created so insurance
doesn't have to be complicated it's
black and white honest rates
from real companies the zebra is the
nation's leading insurance co comparison
site
for car and home insurance they can help
you save money right now it's so easy
go to the zebra.com answer a few quick
questions compare accurate insurance
quotes for free
the zebra protects your personal
information all right so there's no
hidden fees
there's no surprise along the way nope
this is secure
all right you can do it over the phone
from one of their licensed insurance
agent agents with states reopening and
people back on the road the zebra is
committed to making sure you
and your family are covered how much
money can you save on car and home
insurance i don't know man
so check out the zebra.com fighter
that's
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a dot com slash fighter
for insurance in black and white what is
she singing
let's see don't want to be strong like
men who look pretty
i want to be strong like [ __ ] that
fight bears
how she doing the tick tock oh it's a
dub
of what's that tick tock thing i don't
you know i get lost in that world
yeah but damn for her man yeah i'm big
fans of y'all going to this gym man yeah
well dude
you know what man we trying okay we're
motivated now we're really our child now
that that's probably the most like i
think out of all things like because
look
man like i said well we get together
it's like
it's magic now listen but like us
working on the gym it actually felt good
yeah that was fun
i'll do it again steve stevie's getting
a membership there that's christ
stevie's god damn i'm going to get a
membership there's dogs roaming around
well well stevie told me he's 160 and
i'm 174 right now
so are you steve yeah because jamar
neighbors said he was 175. i don't
believe that
you think he's heavier he's heavier yeah
big boys big trucks big [ __ ]
now he didn't want you to lift you
didn't want to go live because you just
got a new tattoo on your hands yeah get
the [ __ ] out of my face
you got a tattoo on your finger hey
they told me to take a week off
i played in football games with
full-blown tattoos and you said
it was in the gym the next day yeah i
said well what's up show me your tattoo
show
this is a little pma show no show the
camera i've seen it i don't know how to
get to the camera oh god
look at the camera just do your finger
like this he was worried about working
out in that you can't see it
yeah you can't see it not on an eagle
angle it ain't like that i have to like
get up to one of the cameras
enough gang signs homie what's up well
either way if you can't see it's on his
finger in there oh it's like blurred out
i was like didn't you am i blurred out
no no you're good now you probably
explains the body
[Music]
i think it's in my story
yeah there it is yeah pma you all got it
yeah i mean the homies toby morris
and uh derek green what does pma stand
for positive mental attitude jay said
[ __ ] money uh yeah
alcohol that's what i thought it was for
i was like god that's intentional you
thought that was
man that's why i thought i don't know
[Applause]
that's a lil wayne song it's punk rock
well no his money over [ __ ] nice pim
uh
p.m w [ __ ] money wheat oh [ __ ] money
weed
that yeah yeah everything you like so
pma
is like positive attitude uh rap report
has it too
stay positive hope uh uh i know that
hurt on the finger
you got it you got to think the worst
but the artist was [ __ ] great this
dude dan smith
uh he's out he's a well-known well-known
tattoo he's from uh
uh not killer inc uh uh inkmaster ellie
um
kat von d show yeah he worked at kat von
d's mm-hmm that makes sense he has that
style yeah and he she's right off
fairfax i think still
uh no uh it's i think it's fountain and
uh
voltage tattooing is that what it is
yeah yeah it's got kat von d
sick for a long time yeah but uh i think
she still does it i'd love to get work
from her
i think she's still she's every now and
then but then she had her own makeup
line for a while that she focused on
doing music oh that sounds terrible um
i think i think she's like two grand an
hour
she's like one of the most expensive
tattoos yeah she's a beast though i
think you know maybe she just doesn't
want to do it
she had a kid maybe yeah yeah she has a
kid now damn look at her she was
so big remember oh god damn that's
incredible
that's ridiculous damn that is
incredible
and he's saying but uh dan smith is dope
go to go to dan's page
dan smith it should just be dan smith
but yeah this is
this [ __ ] uh remember
this [ __ ] part right here like the a
where there's where there's no meat
where it's just bone
oh need on bone did you did you use the
uh
the numbing no we no i didn't use any
anything i just [ __ ] had to sit
through it
yeah i won't get my whole leg done um
his ig is
so someone reached out to his cat on
instagram some dude he's a black and
white tattooer she's in he's in
l.a yeah you need black and white work
let me know
dan smith sm all connected
how did you get connected with this guy
chappelle my boy uh toby morris
uh how
how does wait what are you typing is he
not a stan smith sm but
go to another one chan for god's sakes
that guy is h i-s-i-s-m-i-s-m
you got me he's dope as [ __ ] dude
yeah he does like that traditional
almost sailor old school yeah
vibe and he's a big punk rock guy
yep oh okay yeah big party he's not he's
done some work for uh travis
he's really good at like shoes and those
small things yeah yeah that's a dirt
it's a dope uh trumpet yeah it's dope it
was fun though man
he was killing it now look at that hands
at god damn
bro they say that's like one of the most
painful like they said hands hands and
feet dude
there's one that's painful i think it's
him he got tattooed of new zealand on
his feet
keeps going down the only problem with
getting it on your actual feet
yeah it wears off and it sheds a lot man
what are you talking about
it comes off because it's just the skin
from your foot right there
[ __ ] that look at that and why would you
do your phone what would you do
we can't see it yeah i think that's hey
he knows
he's all right around that space there's
there's probably there's a meaning
behind it you know so that's a news
that's where he's from
yeah but they're like you're stepping on
new zealand no no
no because he has a heart i'm always
walking with new zealand
did i do that i think he did something
ginza you just gonna stomp on your
culture
would you get your mom's face on your
foot you know like you're stepping on
all the time i'm always something that
you love dog i walk with my mom
[Laughter]
are you gonna get more work from him oh
[ __ ] yeah he's gonna do a rancid one for
me
you're about to we're all gonna look
like travis parker in the next year oh
i'm down
except for malik so yeah you me and j.r
yeah and justin
yeah yeah i know yeah because literally
my favorites when that tattoo artist
comes and
just you and i have plans in jason and
jay's always last minute i was just
giving her so is
because i remember one time i don't know
i got a misfits uh fiend skull right
here
and i was drunk as [ __ ] when i got it i
was bleeding a lot
yeah i don't care were you all right
yeah that's all right i mean
well i think it affects the tattoo
artist's ability to tattoo you
because he was like he was like yeah you
guys are overthinking it because he was
like you have you had anything to drink
and i was like i had like one drink yeah
and then uh
i was like why he goes he bleeding a lot
and i looked over and i was just
dripping but i did i was so [ __ ] up i
think a lot of people would do tats
with zany with this cause you go you out
like a like
oh my goodness what did you say like a
light yeah yeah yeah like
man slept through the flight yeah but
taking xanax is wait what
are you going to get done yeah from my
knee down
to my to my uh ankle oh you're doing a
leg a sleeve
yeah you know what you're getting no
do not take any drugs even
over-the-counter painkillers will
increase in bleeding
of course usual drugs such as cocaine
meth will cause issues with william as
well with clients keep it
still while they're having the tattoo
you don't really want to google things
like be careful it's [ __ ] cancer
stage five go see a doctor right now
that is
the [ __ ] it's a mosquito bite
that isn't absolutely true doesn't have
kids do not google [ __ ]
yeah it's always worth it it's always
worst case scenario oh really that's
facts though that makes sense i've been
on drugs you got tats
yeah and you didn't bleed like that yeah
i'm not going to [ __ ] bleed out
oh all right i didn't think i was going
to bleed out but i was bleeding a lot
yeah tattoo's fine it's going to figure
it out you know they'll figure it's a
little bloody
nice little fiend skull yeah really yeah
i'm good
but do you think that was that you're
probably your most painful attack
because this was my most
or my ribs my ribs are [ __ ] oh yeah
you are you have ribs
uh yeah ribs yup that sucked oh my god
you say sternum and throat's the worst
i got my collarbone that's bad i have
raw power right there
yeah you do yeah right there but come on
what's up i feel like neck would hurt
neck yeah you wanted i love that tattoos
i love neck tattoos me too no i don't
want one
i'm definitely gonna get it you could
get it jen stevie's tough
because nothing screams i have a
no he felony to get it and i would tell
him no no yeah that's where he gets it's
a stand up it's dicey too
especially not well known and you get a
neck tattoo yeah you're talking about
prison and i was like god damn
just a tough look to be taken seriously
yeah he is that stand-up guy
that has just all full body tat tattoos
yeah i'll google him he can cover it he
can cover him though right
no no he shows him oh it's on his neck
too yeah everywhere he probably has his
media yeah
oh is he uh he might be out of utah what
does he wear glasses
i think so yeah yeah like his neck is
everywhere yeah i think he's i think
he's out of utah
hold on go to go back oh yes uh
prison tats yeah but even well you
immediately reject your neck tattoo
click on
the neck tattoo that's like legit work
dog it's 38 minutes long
there's some well freddie and the grady
got oh [ __ ] he's tagged yeah he's got it
everywhere
tattoos will ruin your life is three
million views what's his name
shane smith yeah yeah his tattoos will
ruin your life
that's so funny and he keeps getting
them
i mean once you're committed it's like
what are you gonna do my boy
uh toby is tatted up too we'll think
pete davidson's blasted too and he's
getting removed you know that oh yeah
he's getting all these tattoos removed
oh cause he doesn't like them anymore or
to make room for more because i know
some people do that if they
uh have a bunch of tattoos and they want
more they'll like blast one off
so they could get something else on
there i'm doing that i'm getting a lazy
look at this boy
who's the thickie on the right you
that dance kind of like right
my body's better than that hey yeah 266.
yeah something yeah but you look like a
little preppy guy that's what's up yeah
yeah but like i don't know if you saw
him do stand up i don't think it'd be
weird because it's like
yeah if it's funny in your dress yeah
yeah it gives
yeah if you have to address it yeah
that's the thing you have to address it
then after a while then once everyone
knows who the [ __ ] you are
because he has a little especially
especially if you're a good comic
you're gonna be fine yeah i don't know i
don't know any comics with bad tattoos
on your face
he's probably doing he got over three
million views on that video
he must be he's completely yeah those
faces are straight prison tattoos
no bro but the barbed wire
that that well i guess we'll call it a
rose
by his eye that's a rose bros or dick
rose or dick to each itself
let's play a game rose or dick and i'm a
fan of this guy
yeah what a gangster gonna do shout out
to shane smith how about the date night
last night
oh it was fun we went to passed away in
berkeley and burbank
on top of a mountain stevie picked it so
oh you'll
well do you know restaurants while in
l.a nah um
because i was gonna kiss cuz chin picked
the first one and then stevie picked the
second one
i guess i'll pick the third
and then you would pick the fourth but
you don't know restaurants uh
and you're bringing your girlfriend next
time right so we could do it properly
dude white mike maybe white wife was
having a time with him
did white mike have a few drinks right
he was just trying to
y'all talking about narcos we're like
yeah trying to break down
tv because we had two we had two tables
set up and it was like the way they set
it up they should have had like a circle
yeah every time would be way better
yeah the circle would have been better
for that but but you can't say cover
times because we're we're all friends
and we're around each other like
it's not every day to dictate whether we
have covert or not it was a cartel
family had like what
said like 20 people and they was taking
pictures with oh
cast away the way they set up to the
right was like big parties to the left
was normal people
to the left was the normal restaurant
and you went in there
was so funny to the right was like where
the rejects went
i don't know what i didn't know about
that i would have put up such a fight
like
dog yeah i think we were too big for
that section
then we would have cut some people loose
because i'm going back to that place
without you guys oh and i'm sitting in
those regular streets
it was i am his place it was so lit it
was dope
once i saw that the food was good too we
stuck to our diet
man my girls got well cat my girl got oh
my god dessert
we got dessert we had a cheese plate and
we had dessert
dude i don't think i understand when i
saw that brownie and ice cream pull up
bro i'm addicted to food i know i am you
know this weekend how hot
[ __ ] we both addicted to food you know
how hard it was like i
didn't know what i you know i did i
judge i judge cat my girl
you see i gotta we got in the car i told
my girl you know you [ __ ] up
cause you hear me crying you didn't lose
enough weight
well she's lean anyways yeah she always
wants to lose weight but still dog
it was tough and then they had that key
lime i'm telling you i was an attempted
dog i'm at that point
i've been scared i'm so strict i'm not
drinking a gallon of water a day i got a
water bottle that tells me what time to
drink it yeah oh the
uh yeah what is that water bottle it
says like nine a.m keep
going yeah yeah yeah i don't need that
just give me the number i don't need
yours
it's like hanging they're almost there
we're persevering together
somebody's gonna be peeing you know it's
like what the [ __ ]
oh yeah i don't know yeah i i still feel
the temptations it [ __ ] sucks i don't
have any
i had that the one i did is i like re
when i was in my fat days when i was 270
i used to
get coffee i know but i'm i'm below that
now
i'm 264 today woke up too soon
oh why you didn't remind me it's tough
to weigh in with all her clothes on
i gotta wait i get naked why are my
undies on
uh like it's a weigh-in yeah oh you can
do that all right and then my kids stand
with my girl and i weigh in like this
yeah but uh shout out to mike dolce yeah
if you go to mike i think it's mike
dolce.com so mike dolce dolce dyer isn't
it adultery.com
that's what i do all my food text him
all my [ __ ]
meals and he keeps me on track and then
also
more plates more dates have you ever
seen that guy's youtube channel
more more plates more dates oh that's
a [ __ ] genius when it comes to
dieting and he's a bodybuilder and he'll
let you know about like
he's had to do that steroids he broke
down me with my trt yeah yeah
yeah genius but you go to him he has
like
cheats if you're cutting weight it's
great man more plates more dates
oh man that's kind of body i'm going to
look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's great though he's got kratom
on there too
she does yeah tony
kid's a beast like i have no idea how
old he he
listen yeah he might be 20 40. 24.
is he 20 is he 40. no i don't know 20
40.
smart [ __ ] dude breaks it down man
damn 17 getting
on gary 17 that's a bad idea but he'll
also like what
gear you know what he'll do is like hope
like he knows the body so well and like
steroids the way it works
whole like ufc fighters like paulo costa
he'll be like i think he's on
these steroids or michael b jordan he'll
be like michael b jordan probably took
this to get this
big okay or like um uh
tom hardy for certain roles like for
batman or venom
he took this to get this big or like for
chris hemsworth
yeah who like he took this problem oh so
that's what the these videos
break it down yeah his youtube i don't
you know i don't know what he does on
instagram i don't see anything
so you know the body i'm trying to get i
kind of do that but that's why i hired
mike dolce and that's why i watch his
videos because
yeah i know the body but at the same
time like to be held accountable and to
lose weight like i'm doing like
yeah you need to hire somebody that's
what they do like if i if i'm if i need
to fix my car i'm going to a mechanic
i'm not fixing myself
could i do it maybe probably a
half-assed job correct but if you go to
a professional
you're going to see results do you uh
should i be juicing right now
wouldn't hurt you wouldn't hurt you just
do a whole thing on lebron too
what do you say there you are there you
are brendan we need to repost that
damn they put that [ __ ] huge dicks in it
stop working
that's clickbait
the banana you got a pizza he got a
healthy banana you got that one
wanna play a little bit of it i think we
watched it or
was watching a part of it before yeah
yeah oh my dick didn't work either
what dick was was wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute dick did not
work wait a minute while you were on
testosterone yeah
i mean that makes no sense it does
though it does though because uh
because you're some guys derek more
please can't tag me
man and he's mike thought to be like you
know take this do this
it's dope he hashtagged you what did you
say i said he hashtagged you
there you go that's better than you
tagged me dog see you are you he
doesn't get on rogan though 100 we need
to get him on rogan
uh you need what what did i say you said
you need something like he's doing your
diet dog
just just willy-nilly it throw you just
white knuckling this this is this
is [ __ ] you using that tar your tarzan
friend tarzan yeah right
tarzan sent us that diet see we we were
man we worked out yesterday we were
motivating each other
i blew my ribs what you doing yeah
how are you eating i'm trying to
motivate you ain't good you are
intelligent you know
you saw what i ate last night no you
know you know you [ __ ] up right
how did i [ __ ] up you got a new york
strip and that's drying fat
should have had the fillet lean meat you
could cut the fat
there's still fat didn't you you had
lean protein
mike dolce steakhouse what should i get
fam sent me a list
this is what you should order uh the
only bad thing i had high calorie was
the brussels sprouts
there's a sweet glaze on it was eating
i'm like this is not good for me oh i
i didn't eat that so i'm good i had two
plates
i had two i didn't eat that i i didn't
even see you during the dinner
you were so far away oh i know i know i
might tell you
no he's gonna kill you i don't i
your girl why your girl
hey you got a white girl why
i got you a snow ball
you got yourself a six figure karen
g white one you just looking at the
table you say what
i was like i just you know i was like
damn he got her like why why like i'm
white but she won
she keeping me grounded you know i mean
why
did you know she was that white cat i
did not she was like
valley white girl yeah hey y'all
like she gives off sorority white girl
vibes yes
you think so her chin girl oh my god
they love each other i love you but
chin's girl kind of gives me the same
uh vibe like 100 percent just right
sorority
yeah like bubbly it's not a bad thing at
all it's just like their personality is
very
uh like very friendly yeah very sweet
very good
yeah yeah yeah white privilege
that's what it was yeah you're right
yeah you're right you're i was having a
good time when are you
like they had y'all had your own table
no we had our own sides i'm i'm just
saying i
i just i don't see i just you if you
give me a hundred guesses and you lined
up girls then like
this was like pick a date for a mallet
oh yeah she went out here my top
50. yeah she was like oh my god
i was like hey hey hey
snow buddy who brought the snow button
it was so funny because he just looks at
me he goes valley girl why
didn't i look at you because he was
sitting there on the fly what
he just turned was watching her talk i
was like
because because you're not like you know
you're not like
nah i'm not that yeah you're like you're
like a you're an actor yeah yeah yeah
you lived
yeah yeah no no no no no no yeah you're
like a real black guy yeah
she's and she's like a real white girl
yeah yeah maybe that's why it works it's
like yeah opposite of the track yeah
yeah yeah
who paid for dinner yeah she did yeah
but we saw him filling up that check
okay yeah that matt was like
i uh nah i'm just messing with you i
paid for no he did yeah
yeah i'm
yeah what about when mike white mike was
talking about yeah man i posted a
picture of my girlfriend and then they
were talking about it and then we just
look at malik
i was just staring at man bro cause
white mike was like y'all talking about
me not playing please with my girl
so i had to post a video with my
girlfriend
because my girl grabbed this phone she
was oh my god let me see yeah
she was like i'm not on social media
there it is yeah i was like all right
well sweetie
but malik is and he could post
put some pressure on her with the
pressure put some pressure
we're good at it your
[Laughter]
i'm so glad because i know you ought to
pressure me in that situation y'all was
having a time of y'all alive no white
mike was having a time of his life yeah
because he was right here he was in the
middle of both tables
in and out like damn this is pumpkin
good good ass pumpkin who knows like
white mike white mike got invited to
dinner like you've been here before
that's your pill thank you dog you broke
me he said hey
what you eating over there like you
gotta quit yelling dude we're
in a public place oh protein
okay chill out yeah i love i love white
mike he's great
my girl's like what are you calling
white mike and he was like he's he's
obviously white yeah
he's clearly white i'm like that's the
point he's a white guy in the hood yeah
look at the way he's acting
oh loud he's like i love kanye he can do
no wrong
i'm like yeah no i get it he's like he's
a genius he's a giant
i just think he's so smart we can't keep
up with him like well he's not elon musk
i do think he is sort of a savant when
it comes to music
but i was like what about when he's
talking about making his own dictionary
he's gonna create a new language white
yeah oh yeah he did quite quite get
quite a bit yeah that is weird anyways
his new album
yeah i think i do think kanye's like a
savant but i also think there's some
mental issues there
so yeah it's tough to like separate the
two like some of it's genius some it's
just complete
[ __ ] yeah i think i think he's just i
think he's suffering
you can't i think that's the yin and
yang you can't have the genius without
the
you know yeah yeah mental maybe i think
elon musk seems to
when they took elon musk said when he
talks to regular people it's like
like someone like us talking to a
toddler like when he's exactly and
that's why he pauses
yeah between because he's trying to
break down layman terms because his
brain's functioning at such a high level
correct so if you listen to a podcast
it's kind of frustrating because
wrong asking a question and go there's
silence silence and then he answers
yeah it's like it's like who do you it
must be a tough to be that smart in that
high level it must be a bit of a tough
gig
oh yeah you're like your brain can't
shut up they're just beyond
well those are [ __ ] terrible those
are
those reminders so this rapper got a
hold of these
the yeezys i think they you might like
them later
i am not gonna lie i like them now yeah
no i probably i would never
ask your white girl when she thinks
though oh my gosh
she's making god she mixed
really what white and whiter
now she mixed
yeah it kind of shocked me when i saw i
was like okay
did she say did you say native american
that's my favorite yeah that's what
that's what i said you know she said
she's
so what that's what every white girl
says to try to like
say native americans that's what every
white girl says every white girl i knew
it yeah
she's like two percent no i i expert
percentage i like what do you oh you
need to ask him because she's real
native american should i have a card
they give you a card oh i didn't know
yeah i didn't know i was like no
no of course it did yeah she's lying the
thing is
it's every white girl's like like thing
you know
who who's the lady that said it uh a
politician
she ran for president did she say oh you
talk about nancy
pelosi no uh that the girl who
she other one the boy education yeah
elizabeth oh my god she was she
[Laughter]
she get praised though i like elizabeth
native america is [ __ ] with her oh
man now i'm not i'm not saying i don't
get a twist and i want you to think i
don't like your girl
i was just to the cherokee nation on
thursday
she's good oh [ __ ] i'll tell you right
now i take that dna test and there's
native american bro
what you going i'm getting feathered
[Laughter]
like [ __ ] [ __ ] dark hawk in this
have you taken one of those tests before
no
yeah yeah i'll tell you when what is
what is it the 33
i've taken 23andme i've taken the
ancestry.com taking both of them all
right
it's 50 english mama born and raised
there yeah yeah
and then it was like 25 german 20
italian and then a little bit of like
scandinavia i never took that test
do you think you need to no like i was
interested in taking it i don't i mean i
don't know what's going on is it
what do you mean what do you think
you're missing
you
you guys are from africa
me too man it is i'm sick of nothing
are you guys from africa your your roots
fermented have you guys seen this
country
because africa is a continent not a
country yeah africa is huge you guys are
from africa
probably we're probably west side we're
dark west
yeah like african yeah that's happening
you know what you know what that is
that's like south africa right man
how about i'm take back to your roots i
was like oh yeah
oh what so he has a white guy
he texts me yeah he's like he's like if
i'm in the ring with a black guy
i'm take back your room i was like oh
that's the most racist thing i've heard
in quite some time well he takes he said
hashtag nigerian jab
and then i was like what does that mean
and he like how you spun it back i was
like okay cool
yeah it's fabulous it's a kamara usman
reference but it's an
awful reference no one's head goes oh
kamar who's been the jazz no yeah
i was like oh wow that is i know you got
diapers
i was like oh he's trying to get
canceled again
that's what you want to do right i mean
that's your thing because in the third
round i
educate yeah and even then i was like
man like you just sat down
doubling down on it all right well
that's what you want to do buddy
wait have you guys taken the test i've
taken the test but i heard
uh for the most part there are certain
people who won't get very good
results back because there isn't a large
uh sample for them
so a lot of asians don't take it so the
accuracy isn't as great as like if a
white person takes it because
white people are more likely to use uh
those type of services oh so it's made
for white people that's what i thought
that's because
it's just because there aren't as many i
guess like asian people using tests like
that
like my mom told me i was stupid which
like she has a fair point she's like i
can tell you
where your family's from like i'm from
vietnam your grandma's from vietnam yeah
but sometimes they say they take the
test and you're like 50
african your mom's like there was that
one time
that's why your mind sounds like your
mom's like yeah don't you're [ __ ] no
no no no no no you need to look at it
your mom's like well there's a wild
summer
i look exactly like my dad so there's
like no but still i'll take it
you have money now yeah so let's i did
take it oh you did yeah it
did it says your vietnamese a little
chinese and then there's like a small
percentage that always changes when i
log in one day it'll say
you're like part thai and then another
day it's like cambodian it's just like
that general
i can see a splash of chinese in you i'm
like uh
no koreans koreans have big heads a lot
of koreans have big kids yeah yeah
because i i'm like chinese
guys i'm not loud
he did that on purpose the question got
that chinese
did chinese people not have big heads i
don't i think koreans are known for like
uh
rounder faces yeah yeah whatever but i
mean so i wanted to take it because you
said whatever
i don't feel like my brother always
teased me like i was adopted
he would tease me and then i just grew
up way taller and bigger than anyone in
my family the biggest queen i've ever
seen
have you done the test no so i should
probably doing the test
you're going to do the test and report i
want yeah i want to see finally
cover the test do it oh yeah for sure
yeah for sure how much is it
scared it's not it's not much and then
you get the results back pretty fast
like
mike dolce sent me this i sent to you
chin to get my blood to get my
hormones checked yeah they sent it
within two days
you prick yourself you put all the blood
in a little vial you sent to them you
get results back a day later
it's an app and it tells you all your
[ __ ] on the app you just text to your
doctor like this what's going on
instead of like get like the blood yeah
is that doing the whole vial yeah you
just
you prick your ring finger i still got
the mark on there and then you put in a
little vial
and that's it and say that's the one
usps a day later
app shows up this is what you need help
on this is it's dope well what do you do
after that then so you just take it to
your
your doctor because i thought it was
like i text it to him i text it to both
my doctor mike dolce and they're like
all right you're sufficient with this or
your testosterone is this you could do
this
oh okay so that's what it was i thought
it was a whole service where they they
fixed all the stuff for you but you
actually take it to someone else with
the results
i did i do but if you do yours
and and send me tests i can send to my
guys and they'll be like he should be on
this this and this
okay perfect see i do a checkup every
every around my birthday
i'm out with that regular doctor yeah
let's go to regular
so like they take blood every year you
know but they don't run those stuff
tests they're like checking for you know
mm-hmm oh so the proof they're not
running
testosterone and all that the the the
pressure their check is just straight up
for
well it's checking your hormones your
testosterone your free testosterone
your estrogen levels like all that stuff
got it
but your doctor's not running that blood
they got it
they don't give a [ __ ] that's in the way
general doctor you're like oh you have
high cholesterol
you know yeah general doctor how you
know i got high
high high cholesterol because you're
nervous
i'm spitballing ideas there are you have
high blood pressure i have high blood
pressure i do
yeah i found that when i was like 18
yeah yeah i almost got in a fight
did you guys do it because you had high
blood pressure i was about to get in a
fight
and uh the security came in my my chest
was like
pumping like palpitate or whatever and
it wouldn't stop and the
the security guard was like hey man you
know you can calm down you're just
sitting in an office i was like
i can't you know i was like it won't
stop and then uh
they took me to the nurse and they
checked my blood pressure
and uh it was like so they were like you
got to leave school immediately
so i had to leave school go to urgent
care did they are you on medication for
blood pressure
i don't have to be anymore oh that's
good but yeah you were yeah i was yeah
through your diet you can figure out in
supplements
mm-hmm because that's the thing you know
because i was taking it and i was like
because i asked the doctor i was like yo
how long do i have to take this and
they're like uh
until it comes down yeah well they no
they even say that they're like oh you
just got to take them and i was like
that don't make no sense i was like i
ain't trying to just take these pills i
like taking pills
yeah and so i do um and then
i researched dug deeper or whatever and
like ask some people they're like oh if
you just change these things up
especially your diet you work out
yeah and my but my biggest thing was uh
stress
yes this was in high school and i was
you know bro i had a teacher i had a
lady come a teacher i had a lady come
over a nurse come over to test my blood
pressure
and i and like all that stuff and you
know i take nicotine which raises your
blood pressure and your hodos
i drink the most intense coffee in the
world and i did it before she came over
and then she tested my arm she's like
we're going to die any second
she's like have you have you had
anything i'm like oh yeah i'm a nicotine
girl
man i had a whole bottle of whiskey last
night
red meat what else you're looking for
yeah i might smoke a cigarette you know
yeah for the longest time she was like
she's like i'm gonna come back because
no one would approve you for life
insurance
so she came back when i didn't drink
coffee and nicotine i was fine yeah
exactly so
that was the thing with me anytime i
went to the doctor for the longest time
they would have to run it twice because
i would get nervous going to the doctor
and it just was like when i was about to
fight you know the commission would
always take your blood pressure
but like say travis brown or big nog or
cro cop would be here getting his blood
pressure
that's the guy you're going to fight in
and steal cage tomorrow so just when
you're around them you're
everything elevates like you're like a
[ __ ] there and you have these nerves and
anxiety
so they're like your heart your heart
rate's really high like yeah [ __ ]
i gotta fight this [ __ ] monster in my
underwear tomorrow i'm kind of nervous
but they never took that in
consideration they always drove me nuts
they always marked down high
heart rate high let me get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah uh
this year was the first time i've ever
uh oh no second time that i've ever
like gone in and they've tested it once
it was fine
i'm still i'm doing great man ain't no
stress right i get doctors
i get mine at my checkups after the
summer every summer
why summers get wild bro
oh oh you do the whole like everything's
td stuff
yeah yeah you have hot girl summer uh
before but now i'm locked down but yeah
yeah
big boy summer right now i'm gonna get
that summer body by july
everyone gonna be fit oh dude i'm be tan
as [ __ ] i mean that gym my shirt off
short shorts no oh yeah out the front
right i was so i was i was so insecure
yesterday i know like i was trying to
like i heard i was grabbing the bar or
whatever but my shirt kept falling off
i kept like doing this
chabelle's strong though so i put on 225
on hey yeah what you think of me
you're strong but you just you don't
believe in yourself like you could have
powered through it you're like i'll go
down like you don't need to go down
yeah yeah you could have powered through
it you think i could have done that wait
you're strong on the 225 225 which it
you know it's whatever
what's your how many did how many times
did i do that one uh
we're going for six you did four with
help
but you could have done kiss my ass what
you didn't help me on that you helped me
lift it up
are you serious really you know you know
i'm a girl right you know you [ __ ] up
right you know you can't really do 225
right i got my health 25 without your
help yeah yeah
because there's
i don't believe in myself well i'm
saying you could have you you knocked
out two on your own and i helped the two
and then you're like oh you're like i'm
done let's go down lighter i'm like yeah
you could still do this power so 225
is 245's on each side yeah yeah and you
only
got four no he did six he did six on his
own the second set i'm talking about
how many sets did you oh he's six on his
own
just on the last set you're like i need
to go down i bet you could not get at
least four on your own
thanks for believing in me that's what i
like because you're strong that's what i
like yeah yeah
i think you got to start motivating him
more instead of putting him down yeah
you be talking [ __ ]
[Applause]
he got up real quick
the first thing we got in was a leg
because i was straining and pushing and
like it's like
like when it went down you know i was
trying to get that range and just crunch
my ribs
yeah we had like six six forty five
forty five damn off the gate yeah
i'm not up there on it yeah all right
all right yeah i won't be in there at
least twice a week
it is the rest time i ride back i mean
you you are right though cause like
yeah i'll see you at the weight and i
get a little nervous for myself
but like then i like i used to when i
when i was doing it with you i was like
oh i kind of
kind of surprised myself yeah i was
surprised too yeah like with the 185
you're like what's this i was like one
of five like dang and i was like i was
like this justin yeah i was like
hopefully i can do it
you're like this smaller than justin
yeah and you're smaller than just
justin like 110. well you gotta believe
because we just might learn something
you was doing pull-ups the other day you
didn't believe in yourself
shut your ass up all right
wait did i yeah you did not you didn't
believe in yourself you did like four
and it was like you got one more
and your stomach was i think when your
stomach like lifts up and shows
shows it's self-conscious yeah i think i
just need to show it so i'm not
self-conscious about it and then when i
just get a long shirt
now take your shirt off i will not okay
i will not
i will not do that you gotta be nervous
i will not do that so it's twice a week
in the gym for y'all then every other
day y'all rambling on jumping
okay that's right i spot new running
shoes so yeah you run new running shoes
wait on the pull-ups yeah i didn't
believe in myself
no you kept you kept telling everyone so
this is his first day working out and
you know
my first day working out no lifting
weight stuff oh in a minute yeah in a
minute and we did back that day and we
did shoulders
right so just a little bit to show this
was like chappelle's just do like
four pull-ups he's like just four that's
all we need like and then we have the
band just in case
he goes kiss my ass and you know i like
he like the point
kiss mark i'm like bro we're here to
help you not hurt you like make kiss
nice
that was aggressive hey i didn't journal
that day
i'm sorry that's fair all right it's
fair
let's go to some current events
all right okay so a elderly man
recently passed away i believe he is
based out of tennessee
and his whole family did the run through
where it's like oh i wonder what i'm
gonna get i wonder what grandpa's gonna
leave me
when uh they read out his will they
found out that he left five million
dollars in a trust
to his dog he then left the dog in the
care of his 88 year old friend who will
get an allowance for taking care of said
dog with five million dollars
how old that dog's eight-year-old
boulder cup uh border collie
so that dog's gonna live maybe another
seven years then what what happened to
the money just the friend gets it yeah
that's
crazy but the friends 88 so basically he
left the friend of
the friend yeah so he's about to so he
just was like [ __ ]
my family didn't care about his family
where's his dog
dogs bawling that dog is balling and
that's crazy yeah we need tennessee
that's a caretaker it's a girl it's a
woman lulu
oh her name is martha this is lulu it
says all you need to know is that
this woman martha burton may be the
luckiest person on earth
all she's got to do is outlast lulu
she's in the mud
he goes she knows it too just look at
her face i just gotta outlast this dog
man
you gotta do that you already know that
gay pat who did this article he's great
yeah yeah well pat i think his name is
gabe
yeah i think he used to go by gay power
okay yeah i know what you're talking
about
you almost got dicey i know
all righty okay so there is a man over
in the uk
he is based out of sussex right now i
believe he actually
went and called the police and said that
he would rather do prison time than be
locked down with the people he's living
with currently
because over the uk they're on there i
think second or third like
they're super happy they're super locked
down right now the man says that he
cannot
uh stand living with the people he's
currently locked down with now and he'd
rather go to jail
you know how annoying you have to be get
presents back to go to prison right
yeah and he was like man i can't take it
he couldn't go at a friend's house he
can stand up
robert vick once escaped from minimum
security prison kentucky but turn
himself in a motel a few miles away
because it was too cold
because it's too cold jesus christ in
kentucky it was three degrees with
windchill of 17 below
he was frozen he was like [ __ ] i'll go
back to jail oh that's like the shining
he walked in and knocked on my door and
told me to call the law on them jesus
christ vic was sentenced to six
years wow for bernie probably six years
bubba
the lockdown's gonna end soon but he was
cold he didn't think he didn't think
about it he was too cold
when you're cold you do some wild hell
yeah you know when you get frosty
turn yourself back in they find a lot of
people who freeze death naked
because your skin gets soaked like it
gets hot so your brain thinks it's on
fire so
they take their clothes off so they find
a lot of people dead in the like frozen
to death
yeah oh [ __ ] wow not a good way so when
the code whether
your mom plays tricks on you you
hallucinate damn
hypothermia hypothermia
okay so your boy tim tebow officially
announced his retirement from baseball
he was still playing
yes yeah i don't know no he's doing the
damn thing he's probably starting a
family now
the route the road for him to get to the
majors let's see i want to thank the
mets
uh the fans and all my teammates a
chance to be part of such a great
organization i loved every minute of my
journey
but at this time i feel called in other
directions i never want to be partially
in on anything i always want to be 100
on whatever i choose
think again uh always cherish my time as
a mat
yeah think about this dude oh that's his
dog as avatar don't do that tim
but think about this dude he hasn't
played baseball since
high school yeah think of all the
criticism he gets comes from the
i nfl's like i'm going to do baseball
and was not bad
and didn't play since high school oh he
wasn't that bad no
[ __ ] no and you said that baseball is
probably the hardest sport to get into
professionally
oh now you played since high school
split second to know what you're doing
at the plate
[Music]
is that him right there yeah home run
this is triple
a right yeah and this is also a guy who
think about it he could take private
jets he could take [ __ ] yachts
anywhere they're playing yeah you decide
to go with the team
like it's not it's not a glamorous
license they're on the road all the time
you know we're not in five seconds i bet
he's happy
i bet he's happy yeah he's a great guy
just great literally
living that's living his [ __ ] life i
respect it
tim tebow hits a home run it's first
pitch he sees guys it's the very first
one
god's plan guys i remember me and him
we're working out at ufc together
and the coach there tom house who's uh
you know he's
he's a coach for tom brady uh you name a
quarterback he's the throne coach for
him so tim was working with him
and then tim would get done so he'd
spend two hours with tom house on
throwing footballs and then he'd go work
on baseball
i was like why are you [ __ ] with this
baseball he's like cause i'm i'd like to
turn pro yeah
once last time he played he's like high
school i'm gonna catch you god damn mind
sure enough look at that six weeks later
he got he did a big audition for
all the scouts matt signed them yeah
[ __ ] if you can believe it you have to
prove it yeah oh dude nobody works
harder
nobody works starting tim tebow insane
work ethic
insane i stayed up for years because he
tortured lsu tigers in florida
top three best college players of all
time i just hate him dawg
monster and he's so disrespectful
because he'll get on the knee and pray
after every touchdown i'm like
just get up you're right now 45 to 3.
so you guys were actually talking about
this last night at dinner this is a
depressing one uh
vincent jackson's family says that his
brain will be donated for cte research
so he was in bourne colorado but he's a
colorado boy so
he went to northern colorado super stud
there in football and basketball
i worked out with him a number of times
with brad pitt brad i
played with him at northern colorado and
it's just a [ __ ] shame and because
the thing is it's not like
you know when you hear him pass away a
lot of these guys get done playing
football and they get like get lost they
go bankrupt
he had businesses man he had restaurants
he had good investments he had money i
think he's a father of four he's married
and then from cte it was so bad he went
to a hotel from i understand
to florida he was gone for two weeks
then they found him dead
i don't know they say how i die exactly
no i don't think they released
a official like uh super stud
captain of the tampa bay buccaneers
monster yeah
so sad play with the charges he's a pro
baller yeah
my age 38 yeah we're same year came up
same time
monster famous in colorado real monster
well alcohol is one of the reasons
yeah one of the reasons yeah ct yeah
such a shame yeah yeah man
that felt doesn't really do anything all
the other way condolences to vincent
jackson's family it's like yeah but do
something
yeah but [ __ ] do something about it
so that he's donating his brain
to cte so anyway you can really tell
about ct
when you pass away that's the that's the
problem about ct
that's heartbreaking horrible what else
you got
oh yeah our boy peter sent us this who
edits the videos peter said
she knows i'm into creepy [ __ ] with
serial killers songs of the lamb buffalo
bill house
uh become bed and breakfast and they're
leaving exactly like it was in the movie
with clarice
really it's in pittsburgh so if we tour
in pittsburgh that's our airbnb
[Laughter]
um yeah and then you know in the movie
he had that like have you seen science
the lambs oh dude you gotta see
have you seen science yeah have you seen
a cat i have not chin
long time ago yeah [ __ ] sakes guys
all-time classic
but uh he's a serial killer yeah yeah
i'm curious
i think his name is buffalo bill
something bill but he has a
in the basement he has like this what
this well where he put
his victims and that in the in the house
in the basement there's not a real well
that was all the for
for the set so the guy who bought the
houses for people are going to go there
just because of silence the lambs
he's going to build the well in the
house it's going to be sick
i'd go check it's pretty dope it's a
nice house old house
crew when you watch the movie it's super
creepy
okay you guys are talking about peter
our ig editor
fantastic editor um he lives in texas
and he was telling us like
when he was doing some of the edits he's
like dude i don't know if i can uh bring
it in today because the power is out and
i'm like okay just do it on your phone i
didn't realize how crazy this thing was
but in texas
i mean thousands of people are without
power like over 20 people died
so 90 percent still has power but the 10
that don't
it's such a shame water pipes bursting
as well and then the other thing is over
there's no groceries either because the
cars can't get into the grocery store so
it's like mayhem for them yeah also
um and then ted cruz oh yeah yeah that's
really on vacation yes dude so ted cruz
was like yeah this is terrible decides
to dip out
and go to mexico and they've they fought
they found them right like yeah like on
his way back
taking pictures and [ __ ] so he's getting
lit the [ __ ] up for it
lit he left on a wednesday the backlash
came in like hardcore so he came back on
a thursday
from cancun so i but i so and i you guys
know i love texas so i but i guess
people are upset because they want him
to deal with it right because he's a
senator education well it's like the
same remember the
uh uh in australia i think the prime
minister
when all the fires he was in hawaii yeah
it's just like
the worst look yeah ted cruz is so funny
because he's like
clearly it was a mistake yeah he was
like i [ __ ] up clearly a mistake
now here's the thing before you place
here's thing about ted cruz
he sounds like an idiot like when you
see when i come he's like
he's like southern drawl and like you
but you're talking about i think he went
to princeton or harvard
and they asked when the longing uh the
longest
term uh professor who's the smartest
student they've ever had they said
take credit say cruz apparently he's
like a
borderline genius where is he from texas
pretty sure
it certainly was not my intention for
that to be understood
as a non-ketosis
[Laughter]
i want that documented the the the
suffering in heart you just [ __ ] up
i know i love when politicians have to
scramble this problem
solved i want this problem solved i want
the power on we've we've got
most are we doing the power from mexico
though were you working on in mexico
it'd be hilarious if you came back with
the tan apologizing i know right listen
what do you want he's got the courtroom
[Laughter]
let's be honest here and then he [ __ ]
up because he's like listen my we're
freezing my
daughters went down we're gonna have
school let's get out here let's go to
mexico so i decided to make them happy
but then it came out some some troll
you know in this group chat with his
wife the wife
was like we need to get to mexico so
this is the chat this is a legendary
chat allegedly the chat so whoever was
chatting with her
screenshots no we are down at and their
power just went out last night
is everyone warm that must that that's a
must we could all huddle in one house
anyone can or want to leave for the week
we may go to cancun there's a direct
flight at 4 45
hotels with capacity seriously kova
tests to come back which we'll take
there
we'll come back to our own house today
just to sleep there
uh we're supposed to go to cobb on
friday with the emojis like
so you can test when you get there
that's the biggest hold up oh then she
set the flight yeah
yeah are you guys warming up cancun cabo
even boston sounds
even boston sounds amazing i would live
to uh
i would love to go but it's not freezing
on down comforter hot chilis and a
hoodie sadly i can't leave or my
mother-in-law yeah
yeah so his wife you know it's tough on
the
legend allegedly the texts but i mean
most likely it's gonna be it but i mean
if you have kids and they're freezing
because they have no power too right
and you have the ability to fly away but
you're the senator of texas
yeah it's a tough one because you're for
your kids too you know here's my thing
like
he listen when you commit to be a
politician
like it's the worst look you can do he
should have stayed and sent the wi-fi
there you go
he said he he sent them he went to go
with him so that they can go and then he
would come back yeah he's a liar
yeah yeah yeah that's the move like send
them so they're warm and then you figure
it out you stay on the ground yeah
you're the captain of the show yeah yeah
i'm the captain you're gonna go down
with the ship yeah and apparently they
left their dog
so someone took a picture of their dog
in like a win you know jesus a glass
door
but then he has a security guard that
says going to take care of it but then
people are just trying to pile on them
even more
when ted cruz was like yeah my
daughter's you know playing this
got it okay someone along those lines
yeah that's a branch
and they probably sit down and sold it
to tmz [ __ ] and then they sent someone
spent a friend and then so yeah
tmz ah damn
uh do you guys remember the black widow
the pool player the asian one
asian girl no she was like known as like
one of the more beautiful
pool players anyways this is a very sad
story she just got diagnosed with the
ovarian cancer terminally ill damn i'm
sorry
but you guys never seen her she was on
espn all the time
okay i don't watch pool i'm ready to
come on used to come on everybody
is a pool or billard's what's that i
don't watch ether
okay it comes on before the nfl sundays
i know what you're talking about man
you know what i'm talking about or early
2000's i think yeah she was
she killed the game due to ratings yeah
you're right because now they
have nfl countdown yeah i remember her
because she was asian it's like one of
the only asian people
she was choosing
the doctors say months to a year that's
terrible
black widow that was her name black
widow
and she was pretty hot back in the day
yeah like a quick little highlight let
me see
especially for a pool player yeah
i mean most of them are hairy dudes so
that's not a good one
with heels on yeah you know how hard it
is with heels on the play pool
do you know how hard it is are
yeah she was a killer i mean it's cool
how good she is that pool it's not dope
she has cancer
no no um have you been seeing this
there's like a lot of
anti-asian yeah a lot of people are
promoting it as well that's crazy right
they're like no wait yeah this is like
talking about i'm talking about it i'm
talking about promoting like anti-hate
there's something going on where like
elderly asian people are being like
attacked
like sucker punched yeah for no reason
it was like in l.a
bay area what some different parts
they started new york because of wuhan
yeah yeah
muslim had the same thing with some yeah
yeah similar things are happening that
because of kova there
is a increase of hate crimes you know
you know how stupid that is
you know how stupid you gotta be to
attack a random agent older because
they're older because like you know it's
[ __ ]
insane you gotta be are they still
looking for that guy who uh had the
hoodie on and just like bum rushed that
oh yeah i think they're still looking if
they can't catch him yet no
i don't think so because he's like he's
severely injured so like it's a problem
some guy died yeah he died okay i had on
a swivel chin
what had on a swivel in the street come
on man
what they don't push me dude no they're
sucker punching bro
oh that's true i don't know it's usually
my head people are like
small asian women because they're just
people who are more vulnerable wow
yeah and they and what they're taking
their frustration out of because of
uh just kovin yeah they said also
robberies and all that stuff too but it
just seems like crazy because it's
everywhere now like older asian people
are just getting bum rushed by random
people to the point where over in
oakland where
the incident where the old man died
because he was pushed
uh now a lot of people in the community
are actually setting up uh google docs
where you can have a volunteer walk with
an elderly asian person to make sure
they get from point a to the same
yes you know how [ __ ] stupid you have
to be you're pushing it
american asian because of the covet
virus
jesus that's just crazy though depending
on where i walk i'll hear stuff like
that too like [ __ ] asians
they started this covet [ __ ] damn like i
think i've heard it twice since the
like quarantine okay
don't be mad at your government asians
don't lock us down you know it's like
it's just ignorant people that's it i
just think people just holding a
headlock
and yeah in beverly hills they're
robbing people with their rolexes did
y'all see that
really only you wouldn't know that not
but anyone who pulls up in like a nice
car yeah they just sit outside and then
when you get in your car they pull a gun
out yeah
what the [ __ ] bro there's a lot going on
in these streets
alex see what's happening why are we
like give me that all right never mind
wait
no they wouldn't they wouldn't do that
oh man all right
like oh thank you boy you can keep that
yeah
are we gonna have a news report where
chin's in china town and the malik's on
fairfax yeah why stay over there by
merrell so wait oh fairfax
like again yeah right now just right off
melrose that you know where all the
shops yeah
right there like some guy parked his
lamborghini he had a rolex on got out
and got him they he got coffee came back
got him with a gun i tell you what i was
at crossroads
yesterday you were at the crossroads
why were you there because you were with
me during the day and with me at night
no i wasn't uh going on yeah
uh you were there yesterday yeah i was
there yesterday and uh he will be
flossing off
of melrose's [ __ ] oh big time big time
because that's what they may be wow
they'd be loud about it yeah so i see
why like people it's a lot of bad
fashion
a lot a lot of like a lot of lambos a
lot of lambos you've got no cars i saw
that uh
crossover lambo you saw
if they're done right those are dope
mm-hmm they're they're dope inside how
much is that hoe right
200 000 you can get them used good deal
yeah right i see that now i say used
i mean good deal for for a lambo
they're dope inside too yeah that's what
i saw it was a blue they're spicy
yeah they don't get the yellow hey
russell peters
change the color your [ __ ] car that
you got the other one
look at the pink one that's the nicki
minaj no the black or the i
you what you want to do is dancing you
want to do star trooper you want to go
white with black green that's dude that
one's dope that's
that yeah that's that transform what
white with black rims
oh lori harvey just got one her interior
is orange
no i think she got it for herself but
i'm not sure who maybe damn how does she
make money
she's laura harvey yeah no i get that
how does she make me
see i asked myself
she doesn't really sell skinny teeth and
stuff like that but she does have uh
like she has a a line with naked
wardrobe which is a very popular woman's
clothing brand
kind of like a fashion nova of a higher
end so she probably makes bank off that
but then
it that was until recent so i don't know
how she made money before
you know she was yeah steve harvey he's
probably just like here's a million a
month
yeah like have fun mm-hmm yeah and
people forget she's still 23 years old
with just time
so she's getting allowance do you think
he's giving her money oh my gosh she's
ordering mommy's
stocks for valentine's day and hermes
she bought her socks uh yeah michael b
jordan for valentine's day got her
stocks in her uh hermes because she
loves this
the brand dude wow stop
so now in five years when it's a little
rocky she's like where's that michael b
jordan where's that guy at i miss that
guy yeah
cause you're renting out the [ __ ]
aquarium coven running out when it's not
covered [ __ ]
let me know how expensive it is for you
try shutting that [ __ ] down when
everybody's in there keep going
keep going keep you [ __ ] up you set
the bar too high my girl's like damn he
got aquarium like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
quick that's nbj that was a creed i can
do that
yeah i do they're dying for people in
that business
yeah how you gonna eat fish in the
aquarium yeah come on bruh so that's
that's the oxymoron put all the roads
and stuff and my girls i can't believe
you did all i'm like
see there's here's my promise you think
he did that yeah you don't think his
staff put all that [ __ ] together and he
just showed up and paid the bills we saw
the pictures yeah
yeah but you set the bar too high yeah
yeah if they break up
they made it difficult for other dudes
they are going to break you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] this michael yeah you [ __ ] this you
listen no if you borrow you know what i
mean though like because he he bought
socks that's what he believes in well
if they break up yeah she goes with
another dude she was like what the [ __ ]
is this and they stalking on what he did
yeah
well now i think when he gets with
another girl it's valentine's day she's
like oh i saw
i saw what you yielded so you don't love
me like i saw you rented helicopters now
you hit the helicopter
that's a big valentine's gift yeah he's
in love he's a symptom
no he's not yeah he's dope no i like him
i like him i like i'm a fan i created a
please
definitely do a steroid dude anyway
uh my xbox commercial oh yeah so people
i finally saw it yeah oh really where is
it on tv
i saw it on his girlfriend's phone it
comes it comes out on the 22nd oh yeah
by the way
the australian girl you were giving me
acting tips too yup you saw the girl
that talked about you saw the comments
was it was it good i didn't i was at
your table was it
good it was good yeah
he walked by and that's it but he was
that pretty much the entire oh you gotta
you got a bunch of lines and stuff
dialogue no
well it's not dialogue so much it's like
the face of the face
yeah and the body of it yeah oh do you
say that yeah because you see his whole
body is there like
do you do a slogan are you like you get
your xbox no get get connected get
connected get connected
that's your one line that's it and then
it is it on tv it's coming on tv
so fans tag me anyway you see me 22nd
yeah i mean all the major airways
because i need the residuals
yeah it's where they are doing the super
ball well that's not
again that's not my fault it's not on
you yeah okay just know i did it i did
my part i showed you not lying
okay cool it's coming out coming out
that's right who's this number one i was
the number one
she was number two there you go damn
yeah shout out to mike you know you
what else wait going back real quick
just as a tip you know when you see uh
people following you so in apartment
complexes like the one i lived at before
so there was like someone that got
murdered in it and there's also another
shooting
and then so people had nice cars in the
area so you know when you have like a
garage remote or
you know gate remote you go inside and
someone's like kind of behind you and
they just go in with you
just let that person go wherever don't
park in your parking spot because
someone actually
came with a gun followed him to his
parking spot and then you know
rob they do that too because wait what
what is it so he's saying
and the person behind you you know do
you think he lives in the apartment too
it doesn't
you don't know so just if you if you see
someone behind you
just pretend to park somewhere else and
move out before the guy sees where you
park at
oh because you can get robbed easily it
happened on my building
and then you live in uh santa monica i
mean i lived in downtown
it was like a nice building complex too
okay but that's just a simple way for
people to rob you
thank god you got out of there yeah
thank god the streets is crazy right now
it's like world war z right now
what world war z isn't that the brad
pitt
it was a regular zombies zombie yeah no
i haven't gone around i've never seen it
neither great movie i heard a zombie a
couple phantoms
liquors i was getting deonte wild you
and just let it rise
yeah my papa let those look crazy i
didn't want you to like
the hippopotamus i didn't want you to
just
zombie hippos this hippopotamus
ah poor malik thank y'all bro sometimes
it's tough
sometimes yeah everyone has it yeah
sometimes you get through some words
zombie hippopotamus zombie zombie
apocalypse
and i was going to let it slide you're
some [ __ ]
i was so excited that was all
i was like what
sometimes words don't get pronounced
correctly uh
zombie apocalypse there you go too fast
there you
i think that's your go you just speak
too fast hey bro yeah
but it's it's it's great comedy when you
don't
i do say a zombie hippopotamus
i don't know what zombie guy yeah what
world poor zd yeah
oh my god put that in walking dead
[ __ ] is terrible oh [ __ ] all right i'm
sorry i let you guys
good this is like uh one of the biggest
news out
right now them zombie hippopotamus
zombie avocado
because i was so i was so enraged that
she didn't see it
australia took a stand against facebook
got silenced so
um the australian government is telling
facebook that
they need to pay for news like when they
put news on you know their site
they have to pay the news outlets right
uh facebook's like no we're not gonna
pay because we're just sharing like
people just share the news content
right so then facebook literally said
well we're not gonna do that so
now they can't publish any type of news
like if you're in australia
you can't share news or publishing or
see news i guess
yeah wait oh [ __ ] can they even do that
so they're trying to pass the
legislation in australia i don't know if
it's a 100 dollar but for now
you can't do it like if you're it's
weird that we they're still labeled
private companies because such a
every it's such an international tool
you know like how long are they gonna
hide a lot of people use facebook for
their news yeah yeah 100
yeah so what are they doing now so for
right now that stance
if you're a facebook user in australia
this is what i hear something's getting
not allowed too of course
it has yeah okay but you're not allowed
to share news you can't like
publish news like facebook is that sorry
for blocking emergency pages and
sweeping newsband
jesus christ it's it's getting too
censored man
yeah it's not good who the [ __ ] is still
on facebook
[ __ ] everyone man you don't know
facebook's the biggest they're coming
yeah there's a they're gonna come back
you didn't come back i was like
everyone's kind of going past it so bad
i had to get rid of it nah bro it's too
aggressive
you got your business on there well i
have a fan page like a family runner
jay runs it but yeah but like like it's
still possible
it's still popping stupid yeah it's
still the one thing that never
sways they just power through yeah and
the older person's not gonna have
twitter they're gonna have like a
facebook page that's where you get
content
keep in contact with your like immediate
facebook yeah that's why i don't have my
family on my facebook but i never go to
my facebook i keep it because i remember
people birthdays on there like oh [ __ ]
i took mine off you did yeah because
yeah you went only one day everyone's
like yeah
it's just it felt fake to me that's
finished but as soon as i took it off
dude like one two people messaged me
birthdays are tough yeah
unless you got done um what was that so
facebook is tricky too because like even
though there's a ton of users and a lot
of views
no one's really monetizing from those
views like you're just like josh wolfe
he has like you know millions of views
on his smoking show whatever
yeah so he but there's no real way to
monetize it because there's too many
rules or something like that you can
monetize facebook videos i think that
the rules
don't allow you to do certain ones like
the weird one you can't do
what is
i think that's why he can't monetize
whereas like youtube
hey man it's tough to monitor hey man
hey man
hey man hey man hey man all right what
else
all right uh i think that was pretty
much let's see oh this
big milk some some rapper kind of like
that's leaked out
man yeah and then he's getting a lot of
hate over you know this thing right yeah
he said yo
uh helicopter uh i'm gonna
like it's insensitive it's not even a
good layer and we don't know it's the
context either yeah i need to hear the
whole thing
well he had he they leaked the whole
verse uh if you
have that like the words not him rapping
it okay
and uh he he was saying like man y'all
just like y'all some goddamn
sheep you know y'all whatever the media
put out there yeah y'all like zombies
zombie hippopotamus y'all trippin
y'all zombie uh eucalyptus
what excuse me
man i know cody here it is right here so
yeah don't don't worry rp
kobe wait yeah yeah we're going on my
job
that's a song called don't worry p kobe
yeah i'd have to hear the whole song
before i get upset about it let me see
you guys on twitter
there we go let's see oh yeah okay here
we go all right nevermind
oh he took it off i guess so
either way man let's wait until we hear
the whole slide yeah but he let's just
take a snippet yeah i don't think that's
directly there
he doesn't he love kobe so the fact that
they're trying to like
create this narrative that oh he's
disrespecting the family i'm not that
song gonna blow up though because
everyone's gonna listen to it whether
they like him or not yeah yeah
here's more that's a little baby he
doesn't miss
so that's meek's line and the little
baby goes i damn near want to have a son
and so i can name him kobe yeah i mean
i just again like meek mill was saying
yeah they're cursed
oh yeah there's more of it i can't i'll
wrap it
wait let me see if i can click on it so
you can see the whole are you gonna wrap
there you go you go all right here you
go mallet it's your it's your it's your
floor
i got [ __ ] eating on me they never
told me i got [ __ ] in their feelings
about this money
they really owe me this [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] always tell me i'm showing [ __ ]
look
cuz no because he said this [ __ ] i'm
always you know this [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
always telling you that she's going
okay the vision [ __ ] always tell me
that she love me
but she ain't never show me yeah if i
ever lack i'm going out with my chopper
it'll be another kobe
[ __ ] i can tell that they ain't even
never know me cause if they knew me
they'd never show me i don't know what
that means that was in the context yeah
yeah yeah it was dope i think he's just
like
what does that mean i i'll i'd rather
die like because he said the girl
he's having sex with yeah never show
yeah she she said she loved me but
basing out with my chopper be another
kobe oh like she'll show him love after
he'd be gone or something like i don't
know
basically say if if you ever catch me
lacking like him he ain't got this piece
on me
i'm going out with my chopper it'll be
another kobe like you like you see oh we
got meat
he got a rolex on let's let's rob him
like now i got this chopper
malik reading's like a [ __ ] spartan
race it is just
it's muddy yeah yeah you're going
through these crazy albums yeah
you made it dawg i made it give it up
yeah i appreciate you yeah
and let's be honest mcmilla's not the
best lyricist so i'm i'm
watered down bars you know yeah yeah
[Music]
i was apocalyptic not much else other do
you guys ever watch doctor strange
yeah of course you do really yeah yeah
okay so this is cool
danny elfman is my favorite composer so
he's going to compose
doctor strange too what look forward to
that that's horde
doctor strange one was really it was
great actually i've never seen them but
you didn't watch it no oh it was great i
watched spider-man
i watch uh batman joker that's it
so do you know the wanda vision that you
see all the billboards for
yeah i heard that's great it's great so
it's a disney plus
like series and she created her own
world and uh
what they're doing now is they're like
bringing in these characters and they
just introduced like x-men
x-men character uh in there so they're
trying to like combine and is it from
like the 60s
yeah 60s everybody goes that time period
it goes 60s 70s 80s
it's a great i heard it's really that's
the olson sister yeah
yes yes the youngest one good call she's
the one that's killing it right
now the other now i mean they killed it
already they're like scrooge mcduck yeah
they're super rich
the youngest one because she doesn't
what they have a clothing
fashion like everything they were like
the hottest thing ever after full house
they just
blew up yeah i love that movie it's uh
it takes two that's you know
that was an old movie steve goonberg
shout out to steve gutenberg man police
academy yeah
i [ __ ] with police again you actually
watched police academy i thought it was
fun before your time
what i thought was before your time it
is it is freaking amazing oh
amazing that sound effects dude yeah he
was also in spaceballs
you got the beeps boop oh boop you got
the crease baseball
you ever seen space oh that's another
great one you got to watch that one too
great oh yeah
still works though yeah oh i just
watched it with my son great
barf the john candy's barf he's a dog
he's a
human oh really and um is he like a
chewbacca character like a spoof of
chewbacca or something and you said it's
a spoof of skin yeah yeah yeah
have you seen what's that lead character
with his helmet was just this guy from
honey yeah rick moranis yeah
and then he's like he's saying something
all dramatic and he's all
right and he goes i can't breathe in
this stuff
okay so it gets hot in this one
is this supposed to be a penis where in
his costume
it probably is yeah yeah oh is that on
purpose or because i've never seen
something
i'm sure it's so funny okay it's it's
one of the greatest it's oh god
for sure it is that's definitely that
has to be yeah that's it's so great
you have to watch this video it's so
funny man all right
that was fun yep oh and we okay all
right no go ahead and close no this is
for after the show oh word
all right great grand wonderful hell
yeah that's it kids
happy friday uh next weekend uh friday
and saturday i will not be in l.a we'll
be in tampa
tampa florida all shows almost sold out
we're planning on adding this show i'll
keep you guys post on that
tampa florida uh tampa improv february
26 through 27th
and then cleveland ohio hilarities march
11th through the 13th
and then spokane washington is
march 18th my birthday march 20th
uh spokane washington get your tickets
at f-a-t-k-z
dot-com free fight fans i just launched
a new show today on youtube
called what's up with brendan shop i
zoom in with a bunch of peeps and they
fire away questions debates arguments
it's a fun show
it's on youtube right now i'm below the
belt channel it's called what's up with
brendan's job
yep oh yeah let me just check it out
real quick uh oh yeah bring that [ __ ] up
chin
there it is you're converge
i just saw right there
i got a question cool and then you're
gonna have to call into the show
i i zoom uh face to face with a bunch of
different fans like 10 fans
cool another brandon oh another oh
brendan from orlando he's nice uh he's
yeah he's coming to the tampa show he is
yeah
they're great legit questions too it was
fun oh that's dope
yeah that'll be once uh every other week
and then the other weeks are food truck
diaries so oh yeah good [ __ ]
i like that max hallway on monday oh and
then uh
yeah helmet giveaway still going on i
think you got another week or so
the helmet giveaway subscribe to
thickboy.com to have a chance to win the
one of one sign helmet by your thick
friend here
or you can double your chance to win
when you sign up for the newsletter at
thinkboy.com
and or by uh merchandise from
thickboy.com
it's all your thickness thickboy.com you
have february 25th through the 27th
the comedy club of kansas city don't
send me any more barbecue
recommendations send me jim
recommendations no you could eat chicken
though yeah you know but it's still it's
just
you know chicken is the same everywhere
but bro when we had barbecue before the
show
one of them is slowly never done we were
slow never doing it again so all right
maybe maybe i might sneak up some
chicken after the show
but yeah uh february 25th through the
27th comedy club of kansas city
and then march 5th through the sixth
vulcan gas company in austin texas only
two shows so one each night one friday
one saturday that'd be fun man yep and
then uh
uh go ahead and scroll up to that love
is type merch chapellehc.com
for all that ish finally got my hoodie
still waiting on the jacket
uh and i'd wear the hat
would you rock that long sleeve wait
what the long sleeve which one the one
in the middle oh i want the tie-dye
you want the tie-dye give me the tie-dye
get me you gave me the old love is tight
shirt that's whatever
give me the tie light the hat and the
jacket all right bro
damn calm down man and the jacket's on
sale dog
are you still doing your thing malik or
no bro wait oh i have a dream i have a
jacket
i'll bring the the punk the punk
riding one sure oh you have more than
one jacket
we're the only jack you have on there we
we we we are in uh we about to revamp
okay revamp and got your vamp six figure
queen
that's a cool shirt though yeah shirt
right but we're gonna revamp that
purple six figure queen all right i got
you guys
[ __ ] meanwhile we got all his [ __ ]
abilities
every
brian will be back on making a regular
thing
that was yeah oh gee
that was that was that was really great
the rinks
it was an honor i knew it was a
different show because when he gave us a
trivia question chappelle goes apples
i'm like okay
bro i was so locked in yeah but but his
his he said he didn't set up jeopardy
he's [ __ ] fired it's almost
like he did it and then
yeah i told brian come back every week
but he's he's busy with his other shows
which get 40 listeners
so he's trying to figure it out okay so
it's in his corner yeah but he's coming
back he said man that's so thankful man
yeah thankful yeah so that's it i will
see you guys in tampa next week love you
guys
what's up know what it is man skater
died chapelle lacy
got the vans on today man these w
taps i i don't know the [ __ ] collab
but i just know they're really [ __ ]
dope
yo send me van recommendations you know
if anyone sees any dope vans [ __ ]
send them my way oh [ __ ] i like that g
yeah but first though i was starting by
saying this
yo it bothers me when the gods get to
acting like the broads
i was about to flow cause i wasn't
feeling drinking i'd go in
that hippopotamus i got these
i got these right here i got these ovo
fit i got these right here
and then get the detail with the ovo
switch these are like pajamas but they
not they switch
this is a shoe cam oh it's i thought it
was outfit cam mm-hmm
yeah let them know who you are you went
with those travis barker specials
yeah hey holla bodega hooking your boy
up and a shout out
like a glove homie ow
[ __ ] if we're gonna have a tattoo there
yeah
cool that thing's still swollen that
[ __ ] pain
hurt there huh right this is the one
right
oh my gosh i wanted to look at that oh
yeah get on camera
i got that pma all right